Let's go!
This week we have a really exciting exercise for mental strength in the
horses and the connection between horse and rider. So there's a lot of variations
to this exercise but the point of the matter is to put your horse through two
three four different shapes right in a row and you're looking for responsiveness
connection and reaction time on both your part and the ability to follow a
pattern quickly and concisely. So don't worry too much about the quality of each
movement until you've done the pattern a bunch of times and maybe you've done
you're gonna do this exercise multiple times this week. So each movement is
gonna be start out simple and you can make it more advanced as you get better
and better and better at it. And to explain it I've brought you an Etsy
sketch. So first off we have a leg yield towards the center line and then we're
gonna travel straight up the center line and start making a circle between 10 and
15 meters based on your ring. Then we're gonna travel back down the long side in
full straightness. Make a corner according to your horse's level and
across the short side and repeat. So we're gonna leg yield in this case right
and then travel up the center line the same. Circle left 10 to 15 meters based
on your ring size and your horse's ability and then travel down the long
side and in conclusion you can go across the short side and repeat.
So starting with our leg yield you want to remember the leg yield needs to be
more forward than it is lateral and the horse should be leading with its shoulder
going across that leg yield and if you ever lose your forward you need to fix
that first. When you're traveling up the center line think of two train tracks or
two walls on either side of your arms to keep you very straight. As you make your
circle the curvature of the horse should represent the size and the shape of the
circle that you've chosen. So don't make your curve in your horse too great or
too small based on the circle. As you begin to travel straight down the long
side use the wall to help you guide your straightness in head, neck, shoulders, hips,
lumbar. An alternate route for this same exercise would be to work on one
direction at a time. Leg yield across the center line, straight over the center
line, circle right and then travel across the diagonal. This is a great way to help
your horse go forward across the diagonal if they need a slight mental
break and then you can repeat the same side twice or three times. This alternate
pattern is best done in the walk and the trot because of the same sidedness
direction unless you are sufficient in counter canter. You can also accelerate on
the diagonal.
you